das ist das fahrrad von janisch ja nun
schließt sein verrannt und er liebt
fahrrad fahren
[Musik]
jeden tag fährt janisch mit dem fahrrad
ins büro fährt und fährt auch bei
schlechtem wetter erschwert und uns
vorbei und winkt uns zu wir haben uns
hat einen unfall gehandelt liegt auf dem
boden
zum glück hat er sich nicht verletzt
es ist nichts passiert janus steht auf
und dann fährt er weiter
jetzt zeigt janisch sein fahrrad das ist
die klingel mit der klingel klingelt man
sich den weg frei
das ist das licht laut unserem gesetz
muss man im dunkeln immer das licht an
haben
ich weiß gar nicht ob man nicht
funktioniert glück gehabt
das ist der sattel von dem fahrrad hier
sitzt janisch ganz bequem das ist der
lenker mit dem lenker lenkt man das sind
die bremsen damit man keinen unfall hat
das sind die reifen und das ja was ist
das ja das habe ich mich schon die ganze
zeit gefragt warum ist an deinem fahrrad
ein kleiderbügel der ganze gepäckträger
ist verbogen und meine gepäcktaschen
fahrradtasche ist in die speicher
gekommen deshalb habe ich das eingebaut
um eine fahrradtasche hier etwas zu
sichern
jetzt stelle ich ja noch zwei fragen
janosch wie oft fährst du fahrrad
ich fahre fahrrad jeden tag ich fahre
fahrrad zur arbeit ich fahre aber auch
fahrrad einfach spazieren weil ich es
gerne hat hast du ein auto ich habe kein
auto in berlin lohnt es sich nicht ein
auto zu besitzen weil man kann jederzeit
sich ein auto leihen
deshalb ist das fahrrad umso wichtiger
janosch hast du noch einen tipp für
jemand der jemanden
der zum ersten mal fahrrad in
deutschland fährt ich habe einen tipp
aber mehr für die leute die keine
fahrräder fahren sondern spazierengehen
und ost übersehen sie dass sie auf einem
fahrrad weg gehen und das hassen die
berliner das hassen alle fahrradfahrer
in deutschland ein fahrradweg ist für
fahrräder mit und warum hassen dass die
deutschen so sehr
ja weil sie sich das nicht erklären
können warum so ein idiot jetzt ein
fahrradweg läuft das ist der
gepäckträger janus klemmt die kartons
auf den gepäckträger
auf dem gepäckträger transportierte man
übertrieben große dinge
es ist windig und kalt geworden in
berlin das war unsere episode zum
fahrradfahren und wenn ihr jetzt lust
habt noch übungen zu machen zum
fahrradfahren zu unseren vokabeln und zu
den positionen
dann werde doch einfach einen fetzen von
easy german außerdem könnt ihr sie
german abonnieren darüber freuen wir uns
sehr
tschüss und bis zum nächsten woche wir
fahren jetzt noch zehn kilometer durch
berlin nicht jetzt geht die sonne unter
janus fährt dem sonnenuntergang entgegen